Red Pill or blue pill.
Let your curiosity guide you.
Hello world it Saroj and curiosity is
a concept that we're all familiar with.
It's the desire to know
or learn something.
It's something that all of us
have experienced at some point.
It's only human right,
wrong.
Recently a team at Berkeley published a
paper on curiosity driven learning and
they demonstrated how it helped enable
their AI agent to learn how to play the
popular game of Super Mario brothers very
efficiently using the added benefit of
curiosity to help Mario
explore his options.
We'll discuss how it
all works in a second,
but first we need to understand
why they decided to go there.
In any kind of real time environment
scenario where time is a relevant data
point,
whether that's a simulation or a
smart power grid or robotic movement,
we can use a class of algorithms called
reinforcement learning to learn an
optimal policy for our agent so that
it can achieve a predefined objective.
That objective could be
any number of things.
Transferring power across
nodes at the lowest cost,
detecting intruders in a real time
security system or just winning a game.
An Ai agents policy then is a function
that given an environment state,
we'll return the optimal action that
an agent should take to reach that
objective.
There are several possible functions that
our AI agent will need to approximate
in order to learn the optimal policy,
and several known techniques
can help it do that,
but of all of the function
approximation techniques,
neural networks have shown
the most promising results.
Thus using neural networks to approximate
one or several functions involved in a
reinforcement learning scenario is
considered deep reinforcement learning or
deep RL,
and it's no secret that deep RL is the
hottest subfield of AI right now with
many researchers adding to the scope
of human knowledge on the topic every
single week.
One of them being the research group
that we're talking about in this video,
they first identified two key problems
with all reinforcement learning
algorithms. The first is the
problem of sparse rewards.
That's the time difference between
an action and its associated reward.
For example,
if we use any reinforcement
learning algorithm to learn
how the game of breakout
works,
it would get a lot of reward feedback
immediately because it's such a fast paced
game.
But in a more complex scenario like say
splinter cell trying to sneak into a
high security facility,
I miss this game.
It's not immediately clear
what the rewards are for doing.
Some set of actions will have to wait
until much later to see how an action
plays out towards the
larger goal of sneaking in.
The second problem is that
extrinsic rewards are not scalable.
That means rewards that we humans define
extrinsic to the agent work well enough
for simple environments.
But when we scale to much
more complex environments,
there are lots of rewards that we'd have
to think about and and code into the
environment for our agent to learn
from hand coding these rewards is not a
scalable approach.
So their solution to these two problems
in reinforcement learning was to define
a reward function that was
intrinsic to the agent,
meaning that the agent generated by itself
and they called this reward function,
curiosity.
They were inspired by the fact that we
humans are so used to operating with
rewards that are extremely sparse.
For example,
some entrepreneurs will toil away at
building a startup even if there is no
immediate reward insight,
their businesses could be failing.
They could be running
out of investor support.
Yet some entrepreneurs
will continue despite this.
I'm not really sure who fits into
this category, but uh, anyway,
psychologists call this intrinsic
motivation, otherwise known as curiosity.
The entrepreneur pushes through the
uncertainty guided by the question.
I wonder if I can do this and
tries to answer it by doing it.
The researchers define curiosity as an
intrinsic reward that's equal to the
error of an agent in predicting the
consequences of its own actions given its
current state.
It needs to be able to successfully
predict the next state given the current
state and action taken.
The basic idea of curiosity is to
encourage an agent to perform actions that
reduce the uncertainty in the agent's
ability to predict the consequences of its
own action.
This uncertainty will be higher in areas
where the agent has spent less time or
in areas with more complex dynamics.
To measure the agent's error,
we need to build a model of environment
dynamics that predicts the next state
given the current state and action.
The question then becomes how
do we calculate this error?
Let's take a step back.
The question we're trying to answer is
how can our agent predict the next state?
Given our current state and our action,
we can define the curiosity as the error
between the predicted states given our
current state and action as
well as the new real state.
In the case of our video
game or agent is Mario,
and each state will be a game frame
which consists of a bunch of pixels.
The problem though is that there are so
many pixel values to predict in a single
game frame, so the entire process will
be very computationally expensive.
They decided that making a prediction
in the raw sensory space of game pixels
wasn't the optimal way
to frame the problem.
So they instead transformed
the raw sensory input,
which is an array of pixels into a lower
dimensional space that only contains
relevant information.
But what do we mean by relevant?
What makes some data relevant and
other data irrelevant to our agent?
The way they ensured that
it only contained relevant
information is by defining
a rule for what data could be
considered relevant beforehand.
Relevant data.
It needs to model both environment objects
that can be controlled by the agent
as well as environment objects
that can affect the agent.
Everything else is not in the agent's
control and has no effect on them.
And we can discard that. So in our
Super Mario game, our agent, Mario,
would need to model himself.
Since he's controlled by the agent
and as the enemy Coupas approach,
we can't control them,
but they can affect our agent.
So they're relevant. Keep
your enemies close, right?
We don't need to model the cloud in the
sky because it doesn't affect our agent
and we can't control it this way.
By constraining what data we represent,
we can develop a feature representation
with much less noise and our desired
embedding space. We'll be compact
and informationally dense.
So the researchers introduced
the intrinsic curiosity
module to help the agent
generates curiosity. This module is
composed of two different neural networks.
Instead of making predictions from a raw
sensory input space of pixels directly,
we'll need to transform the sensory input
into a feature vector where only the
information relevant to the actions
performed by the agent is represented.
And in order to learn this feature space,
we can train a neural network to predict
the agent's action given its current
and next states.
Because the neural network only predicts
the action it has no other incentive to
represent within its feature embedding
space the factors of variation in the
environment that doesn't
affect the agent itself.
We can then utilize the learned feature
space to train a model that predicts the
future representation of the next states
given the feature representation of the
current state.
And the action.
The prediction error of this model is
an intrinsic reward to encourage it's
curiosity. We can formalize
these two models mathematically.
The first is the inverse
model which encodes the state
s and s plus one the next
state into two feature vectors that
are trained to predict an action.
The second is the forward model.
It takes us input a feature vector and
predicts the feature representation of
the next state.
The curiosity of our agent then will
be the difference between our predicted
feature vector of the next state and the
real feature vector of the next state.
Thus,
we can construct the optimization problem
of this module as a concatenation of
both inverse loss and forward loss.
They trained their agent in the Super
Mario World using only curiosity based
signal without any extrinsic
reward from the environment.
They're Mario agents could learn to
cross over 30% of level one the agent who
received no reward for killing
enemies or avoiding fatal events,
yet it automatically
discovered these behaviors.
A possible reason for this is that
getting killed by the enemy will result in
seeing only a small part of the game
space satisfying it's curiosity.
In order to remain curious,
it's in the agent's interest to learn
how to kill and dodge enemies so that it
can reach new parts of the game space.
This suggests that curiosity provides
indirect supervision for learning
behaviors. Pretty cool stuff,
right? As we learn more about Ai,
we learn more about
ourselves and how we learn.
There are three things to
remember from this video.
Reinforcement learning suffers from
sparser awards and extrinsic rewards,
which are not scalable.
A solution is to create an agent that
creates intrinsic rewards itself using
curiosity and the intrinsic curiosity
module consists of an inverse model used
to learn the feature representation of a
given state as well as a next state and
a forward dynamics model used to generate
the predicted representation of the
next state. Please subscribe for
more programming videos, and for now,
I've got to explore, not
exploited, so thanks for watching.